and here we go and Anish Gary recently
released a chessable course on 184 he's
played one E4 and that is met by the
French defense from Magnus Carlsen
another area that anishigiri is a
specialist another area that he released
a chessable course so this is
interesting for Magnus uh we very rarely
see the world number one choose the
French defense it's maybe one in ten
that he chooses this opening and we see
what we call the classical variation
whites gained a lot of space in the
center by pushing pawns forward back has
been kicked back slightly black is
passive but solid and this Pawn push
does hit that black is going to actually
expand through pawns forward on the left
side of the board and wow I've got to
say this shows that Magnus Carlson is
Out For Blood he's out for the win even
with black he doesn't want to play it
solid because uh this is far from a
solid Choice Ivanka it definitely is not
a solid choice I mean I think he's
Magnus was relying on the ghosts of the
FTX crypto cup because there I can
remember Magnus did in fact play the
French defense and he beat Anish with
the black pieces but Anish has kind of
said why are actually going to play
something completely different there I
played the advanced variation here we're
going to go for a lot more classically
but Magnus well he's made his intentions
very clear by advancing that little that
a pawn one square forward he wants to
take as much space as possible on the
left side of the board and I'm expecting
Pawn to go forward yep it's there
and now we're going to see a very crazy
position where it becomes a race yeah
White's King is gonna see whether it
comes Under Fire on the left side
meanwhile white will be trying to blast
the position through on the right side
of the board yeah and Gary takes the
time out just to stop and just to try
and at least deter the advance of
Black's pawns on that Left Flank you
notice how giri just looked away for a
few seconds and then he looked back at
the screen and made a move that's
because he's just recalling maybe what
he suggested in that chessboard course
or what he's studied before and we also
saw Magnus just a few moments ago
staring straight down at the camera at
the computer screen because he's also
trying to remember what he's prepared I
don't think either of the two players
will have studied this this morning if
anyone it would have been Magnus but
there's no chance that giri predicted
this opening and this queen move
I've got to admit I'm not the biggest
friendship defense expert in the world
but I've never seen this queen move
before it must be quite rare usually
Black's Queen Parks itself on a safer
Square the queen here has some ideas I
mean it's pinning White's Pawn on the a
file it's maybe looking down at the
white king along the diagonal but
Black's Queen is a bit vulnerable as
well on this Square so uh this feels
like it will cause giri to stop it will
be a small surprise
um Ivanka do you know if there are any
games or any Grandmaster games in this
many many Grand Master games here
actually and it's I I was just checking
the computer assessment actually Top
Choice of the computer to come out with
the queen like that I mean some very
strange moves have been played
um the most popular one is actually Pawn
takes porn but uh I have to highlight
one weird and wonderful move that has
been tried out before and that is
actually white lifting The Rook one
square forward to the 80 Square
[Laughter]
I guess the whole idea is that now the
White Knight defends The Rook so for
example if Black's Pawn pushes forward
the pawn can safely be captured Black's
Queen cannot snack on The Rook now
because it is defended and in the game
giri of course he wasn't going to play a
weird move such as this one it's not
guru's style he's a very classical
player he moved his Bishop but now
Magnus does have the opportunity to push
this Pawn because now it is poisoned you
cannot take and because the Rook is
undefended in the corner so that's a
very sophisticated concept moving The
Rook to a defended square but
um I don't think Gary would have wasted
any time pondering this if Magnus does
push the spawn forward now then you
can't take it of course but you can
simply step back with the knight uh this
Knight is threatened so you can step
back for example to this square or maybe
even the square it came from
um you can Retreat to three safe squares
take your pick and attention kind of
continues you maintain your Pawn Center
as white yes there might be trades at
some point there might be a capture in
the center but you do hold the strong
point for example if there are a bunch
of traits as long as you hold an outpost
here and hold the space Advantage with
these two points then white is very very
comfortable Magnus meanwhile in the
current position we'll be trying to
break down this Pawn chain
and normally in the French defense it's
all about whether white can maintain the
center if you can you have the advantage
if you can't then uh yeah your position
tends to crumble
and uh yeah Gary as well with his last
move moving his Bishop the way he's
saying okay I'm too worried I'm too
scared I'm too worried about castling
into the firing line on this side so I'm
gonna go the other way I'm gonna run
away from the side the black has just
chosen for his Queen
such a tense position uh a very exciting
opening because both sides really going
for it and it's just a question of who
is going to be more successful with
their space grabs and here we have the
night just as David predicted the Knight
Will Retreat it has and uh isn't that
pawn very far off the board it is it is
and it might be joined by a fellow as
well because I've seen some games in the
database have continued with black
actually pushing the C Pawn one square
further as well you know black is really
adopting the maximalist approach saying
I don't care what you do on the right
but the left side that's mine yeah and
normally we talk about Pawn chains um
it's always the the kind of Direction
your central pawns are pointing that's
the side of the board you should play on
so White's furthest Advanced pawns are
these two in the center we look at the
central pawns first and that means you
should actually play on the right side
of the board later on if Black's King
Castle's here white will attack this
side and likewise for black the central
pawns here they're pointing to towards
collect towards the queen side so
actually with this nice Pawn chain that
you've created it's actually Connect
Four right now that does show that black
should be playing on the queen side in
this direction so that would be really
interesting it's not really magnus's
style to block things like this he he
likes to keep flexibility he likes to
kind of chip away at the opponent's
space especially in the middle of the
board but this does look very tempting
yep it's uh one of many Alternatives
another alternative as you mentioned
maybe more in keeping with uh Magnus
stylus actually to again prepare for
space grabbing on the left and actually
to move the Rook from the A8 Square to
B8 planted on an open line and get ready
to initiate some trades yeah later on
The Rook might well have Targets on this
uh soon to be open file so yeah really
fascinating position already it looks
like both sides are out of book as we
say freestyling he does go for that
option you mentioned there Ivanka
improving the black rook and we're
definitely going to see action in this
game anishikiri runs away with the white
king very safe very sensible and it is
Magnus maybe with the more difficult
decisions to make at this early stage
White's moves are very natural just
developing next maybe trying to reroute
this Knight bring it off the back rank
but uh yeah we will see a lot of
entertainment I think here and I I just
love this approach from Magnus it means
he's kind of showing to Gary He's not
afraid to fight it just depends whether
Gary can Embrace that and uh not be
afraid of that hand-to-hand combat that
we will see shortly yeah oh I like this
one I found it very interesting as well
because I I saw a comment from a former
world champion vishiana and who said
that most people when they play Magnus
Carlson they just can't handle the
pressure they can't handle their
emotional tension and they just try to
simplify things they try to create a
draw as quickly as possible and we've
kind of seen a little bit of the same
from Anish you know we've seen him
perhaps agree draws in positions where
he should have pushed harder and the big
Trend that I've noticed in their match
encounters is that Anish normally starts
off well he applies a lot of pressure to
magnus's position and then it's always
in the last two games where there's
almost like a complete collapse
so yeah you're right Ivanka I remember
at least I think two or three separate
occasions in matches where Anish she's
had dominant positions he's from a
position of strength he's just forced to
draw or taken the kind of the safe way
out rather than really kind of
knuckling down putting the foot on the
accelerator and going for Magnus
so yeah he's got to change that today we
have seen a switching strategy from
energely in the first two days of uh of
this tournament and that kind of paid
off you want to really tense tie breaks
because he was aggressive because he was
uh really kind of uncompromising with
this play and that's what I want to see
today from him yeah yeah and whilst
players are deep in thoughts well it's
going to be an exciting day of Chess I
can feel it in my bones and we love it
when you're at home also join in on the
excitement and all the action and for
today's quiz we are asking you at home
to share with us your best chess picture
so it can be a selfie of yourself
playing chess it can be a cool chess
picture that you've seen we don't know
we you guys at home are always like
creative and you impress us with it in
Ingenuity so as always you can tweet us
using the hashtag chess Champs and we
will feature your pictures on the show
yeah in honor of the Twitter King and
selfie King in each gearing maybe yeah
we're doing this maybe we can get a
niche to take a selfie as well
he is sharing a lot of them on Twitter
and actually speaking of that the start
of the year was super dramatic for a
niche with his Twitter account being
hacked and just some awful messages
going around
the story kind of just ended do we know
anything more about that was because he
he did file the police report to try to
find out who did it yeah it's still a
mystery he's one of the great unresolved
Unsolved Mysteries of the Chess World
and yeah I mean for both of these two
it's really been a dramatic emotional
year it really has turmoil that course
with Anish Gary I know he was quite down
for a while it distracted from his chest
his results dipped a bit after that that
whole incident and yeah Magnus of course
now he's still uh in the thick of that
drama so yeah for these two it must be
refreshing for them just to focus on the
chest just to kind of brush everything
else away but
um yeah what a year it's been 22. yeah
non-stop for drama yeah it does feel
like chess has been in and out of the
news and I have to say a lot of it is
Magnus actually because of course he
made the news when he decided he didn't
want to play the world championship
anymore you know he was gonna
abdicate and that of course made the
news and then of course the cheating
headlight Scandal has also rocked the
headlines and it's really kind of caught
the imagination of the mainstream press
yeah I mean David was just telling me
that it even made the have I got news
for you segment which is a very popular
game show quiz show in the UK and I
think it was on also on Trevor Noah you
know the whole world has has kind of
chimed in on it and had an opinion
yeah chess is far from boring that's the
one thing that the world has learned
this last year
um yeah somehow attracts uh all this
controversy and uh for good and bad
reasons but uh okay meanwhile Magnus
he's taking a controversial decision a
very committed decision at least he has
blocked the center so he's gained a huge
amount of space now on the Left Flank
but it actually might not be happening
there so that this is the big question
can Anish giri switch his attentions to
attacking maybe the black king for
example to giving the white pieces some
energy it is very very blocked but white
is ahead in development white has
castled whites Queen White minor pieces
they're all well placed so it does
somehow ring alarm bells in my head this
porn block from Magnus it's not 100
clear what his next two or three moves
will be meanwhile Gary does have a
little bit of time to try and blow
things open and uh Ivanka what would you
be thinking of First Hill instinctively
what ideas come to mind for white
uh instinctively because a lot of the
tension has just resolved after that
pawn advance I would be looking at
sealing up the left side of the board
maybe pushing up the a pawn and the
reason I would touch that pawn and
commit that side first is because then I
can just focus all my efforts on the
right side of the board and that's just
basically as David is highlighting
blasting through just open up a line so
that the Rook can infiltrate the minor
pieces can get in and that would be very
deadly yep as soon as you block it up
you can focus purely on the black king
trying to open lines towards it I think
you do need to take a time out as you
say Ivanka and there are maybe a few
ways to block it up but if you maybe
relax one move uh too early if you just
improve your knight which Anish wants to
do then maybe Magnus does have a small
threat of Pawn takes pawn and the whole
idea is now there is tension between the
Queens if the Queens disappear say white
recaptures the pawn an end game might
actually favor Black because black now
has an open file this is a very weak
Pawn targeted by Black Star Square
Bishop at some point
um here white Central space Advantage is
far less relevant with Queen's off the
board but yeah I like this move you
suggested if you can't just block it not
allow open lines then suddenly what is
the black queen doing very unclear what
is the black Rook doing it's not on an
open file Black's pieces if you look at
them they actually lack active squares
they're very cramped especially Black's
Knights and meanwhile it's easier for
white to improve and we highlighted this
F5 break pushing the pawn forward that's
purely to open lines up for the white
rook and that's also because the black
king sits uncomfortably in the center
and no matter where it goes it's going
to be a clear Target even if black for
example gets time to move his bishop and
Castle to the king side how many
Defenders are around this King not many
at all and we've seen far too many
examples on the tour this season of
lonely Kings with Queens on the the
other side of the board far away from
the defense they do tend to get
checkmated these types of Kings so I
would be worried for Magnus Carlson here
gearing does need to take I think an
ambitious decision like this one the one
thing he shouldn't allow is a queen
trade as we showed
I think that would be against the spirit
of the position that would play into
magnus's strengths and he does block it
up that is a great move for Manish giri
um at least the spirit of it is uh very
very promising and now Magnus has to
justify his earlier play yes Black's
pawns look impressive but what next you
can't really push them forward
effectively right now
for example even if you push forward try
to force this queen exchange again white
will just say no I will just lock it up
and black can do what he wants on this
left side now he's got a great Point
formation here but the rest of his
position the other half of the board
that's uh definitely favors White
so yeah I'm loving this decision by
Anish time Advantage too yep me too uh
this is the kind of position that when I
was younger I used to dream about I used
to play these positions and I used to
enjoy them so much because the plans are
so straightforward and it's just really
about pushing pawns and even if you have
to sacrifice material just do it
yeah you know
absolutely anything in that quest to
open up a line and Magnus developing his
dark Square Bishop very good
but uh yeah is coming yeah the storm is
coming you won't feel comfortable even
if his King gets to safety by castling
I'm expecting a niche to build up before
this F5 push over the next few turns
looking very promising for white here
the computer does tend to be biased in
situations with this Pawn structure
especially uh the D4 E5 as we say
against uh black spawns here because
white has a space Advantage so computers
tend to be biased towards the side whose
pawns are further Advanced but I tend to
agree with the computer here it must be
very very pleasant for white the niche
needs to seize this opportunity now he
needs to generate some momentum
Magnus yeah he's taking huge risks
actually in this first game
it's going to be a cool match between
these two I have a feeling this is only
game one out of four rapid games between
Magnus Carlsen and each Geary in their
match today
if they are tied they will play Blitz
and potentially armaged on tie breaks to
decide the match and I have to say I'm
loving what Anish is doing such a classy
move you know just retreating this queen
one square and just this is both an
aggressive move but also defensive move
because there were ideas of black
perhaps as David indicated pushing pawns
forward trying to grab some squares
Force his pieces just to try to
infiltrate on the left side and this
queen takes away that threat but also at
the same time she's planning to dash
over and support an attack on the right
side of the board I am just in awe of
this move very very classy sophisticated
can't praise it enough yeah
multi-purpose chess that's what we love
to see and we'll see exactly what we
just showed actually Magnus gaining all
the space now on that Left Flank but
Anish he's gonna Dodge this queen trade
the tension between the Queens he's
gonna block it up surely I think he us
to otherwise things might start to turn
finish does not block up that diagonal
just by pushing a pawn forward I would
literally fall off my chair
I mean I don't know why he's thinking it
also moves the White Queen he could also
bring the White Queen to the right and
start attacking but no no no no need for
that kind of mess just block it up
simple chess and I see it a lot on
Twitter actually Yoli server learning
point has kind of become very popularity
everyone's saying keep it simple yeah I
think that's just the key to chess
Mastery and uh there we go he keeps it
simple you don't have to fall off your
chair your Banker
we have some wolves on the board but uh
before we talk about this pull and push
by uh Anish we're gonna go to San
Francisco that's where the action is
happening today with
two matches four players playing these
two matches in San Francisco so much
action today Tanya how are you guys
doing in San Francisco
oh we're loving it as you mentioned all
the matches that are happening inside
they're playing each other so that's
always fun to watch and one of the cool
things about this tournament Kaya is the
involvement of the local community here
having such an event every day we've got
these special guests coming in telling
us about the local chastine and today
we've got one such guest with us he's a
chess player himself he's also a
streamer a very popular streamer I've
got with me International Master David
Bruce David Welcome to our show hi Tanya
thank you for having me David it's so
it's so nice to see the kind of
involvement of the chess Community here
in San Francisco what does it mean to
have the finals of the tour here in your
city
I hadn't thought of that it's a good
question
um I think that uh for a lot of the
people I know in San Francisco they were
talking about it as it was coming up and
they were pretty excited that it was
going to be here so I think um I think
it's really cool just to just to imagine
that Magnus is in your hometown or or
maybe not your hometown but your town
you're living in now
absolutely and we've also got Wesley
playing here who's quite a bit of a
local healer hero after his win in the
global Chess Championship yeah Wesley is
uh you know coming into this event
extremely hot
um incredible performance in the global
championships and uh yeah I mean the
first time I met Wesley was here he was
visiting the Bay Area so
um I think he's got a lot of fans in
California as well yeah we love it when
they come here and they're rooting for
him uh now uh David you're also a
streamer and one of the big moments
during the tour was what happened in
Miami with Hans uh and then following
that in the Julius uh Generations cup
when Magnus refused to play against him
now this has been a big discussion in
the streaming community and I want to
ask you what has been the view with your
uh with your audience and what do you
make of it
I think that my audience like the normal
people watching my stream have been a
little bit slower to past judgments than
what you see in the general chess
community in the general trust Community
I feel like very very quickly you had
people who were like
Hans is a hero these evil corporations
are trying to like you know
crunch him under their feet or something
like that and then you had other people
who were like big fans of Magnus and and
believed in his side of it
um on my stream I think
people are more reflective and so
they're sort of like waiting to hear
information and they listen to each
other and they hear other sides of it so
um I'm very happy that
the conversations in my stream have been
very civil and I wouldn't say there's
been a really strong consensus around
whether or not Hans cheated how whether
magnus's response was like the best
response or the second best response or
the worst response
um it really hasn't been very very clear
um
is there a lot of support for Hans uh in
general in the American chess community
that's hard to say because most of it's
now on the internet and you don't
necessarily know where people are from
you know I um
as you know I've got a couple kids at
home so I don't get to hang out at chess
clubs as much I hang out on the internet
and you don't know if people are from
America or not when they are uh cheering
for Hans
um
but yeah it seems he has some support uh
it's a little surprising to me but yeah
all right and what about here who are
you rooting for in this one
for a lot of people I love most chess
players so I kind of root for everybody
on
on but I probably would like to see
Magnus win again
actually in this series of events I
thought like
maybe these tournaments aren't that
exciting because Magnus is always going
to win
um but it's been shaking up a little bit
and we've had some other people winning
you know um Young Chris stuff Duda has
uh you know beaten him in the
semi-finals I think at the last event
and definitely you know provided a real
Challenge and you know prague's taking
games off of him and so forth so I think
it's become a lot more exciting uh if
harder to predict
I couldn't agree more with that
leads with Magnus Carlson we've got
moves on the board back to you guys in
the studio thank you
absolutely thank you Tanya and David and
Anish Geary is uh really trying to beat
Magnus Carlsen today the bar is waking
back and forth we had some moves what's
happening yeah it's a really complicated
position very tense as we mentioned and
uh anishikiri he's burnt his Bridges
he's already committed he's gone all out
and this is the spirit we wanted to see
from energy giri but the execution of
his plan maybe hasn't been the most
accurate objectively he's now jumped in
he's using the dart squares to try and
break into Black's camp and out here we
see a trade of Bishops Magnus happily
allowing that and uh okay right now we
also see black upper Pawn let's jump in
to show what did happen just the last
few moves they've been really dramatic
and this is the current position
if we we rewind to where we left it
earlier black now uh was going after
this Pawn but I think anishagiri rushed
slightly he pushed the pawn forward
sacrificing but he could have built this
up in the break there we were talking
myself in Ivanka we were saying oh just
build up push this button you can maybe
bring your knight forward as well just
build up slowly push your pieces into
the attack but Anish said okay my pieces
are ready he pushed forward are they
ready though with pieces on the back
rank Magnus just uh quarters Bluff
captured and we saw White's Queen come
out attacking a pawn the pawn moved and
this is how we reached the current
position White's Bishop jumping in and
now captured and here if white gets one
more move it looks very scary White
Queen is going to jump in start creating
some really nasty threats the black king
is still stuck in the center because it
can't Castle uh if it castles it will
get checkmated this white king the White
Queen is simply going to come in and
trap it but uh Magnus says okay I'm not
going to commit I'm going to leave my
king in the center forever it's still
relatively blocked so uh he drops back
going after a second Pawn getting greedy
white tonight trying to create some
threats and the big question here Ivanka
is can Magnus survive if he just
continues to call Gary's Bluff and take
support
it does look a bit scary it looks like
the White Queen might jump in
and uh does Magnus have an answer to
this the evaluation Bar says yes black
is doing very very well but from a human
point of view it is
um it is a bit nerve-wracking with the
king in the middle yeah definitely I my
instinct actually wouldn't be to capture
that pawn my instinct would be to huddle
into a ball and uh just try to
overprotect every single point that I
have and you can see Magnus there
sliding his Rook one square over to the
right so the bar so you know clearly
saying hey you should have just been
greedy but as David's highlighted the
whole idea is just simply to trade off
Queens yeah so now this does take the
sting out of White's most natural idea
bring the queen in because uh the queen
exchange is almost obligatory here uh
White Queen would have to retreat to a
very odd square if it wants to dodge
this exchange and remember a queen
exchange will favor Black because black
has won a pony giri has made a sacrifice
and also long term these pawns don't
look great now but long term in the end
game they are very close to promotion
squares already and Magnus always loves
to play for long-term ideas so this is
the current position this is maybe a
small small threat in the position to
come back with the black queen
re-centralize her bring her back to the
defense and trade off so Gary has one
move he needs to find something both
sides have basically the same amount of
time on the clock and uh Gary this is
great play from him in terms of
attacking being on the front foot
but he needs a follow-up it's uh it's
already getting critical if he finds
nothing over the next two or three moves
Guru he's just a pawn down with a lost
position if you find something though if
he can trick Magnus then he has great
attacking chances yeah and but is there
something I'm racking in my brains and
I'm thinking you know I can't see a
thing yeah I mean the other idea that
sprung into my mind immediately was to
capture and only now to jump in with the
queen now black doesn't have time to
jump back and Retreat because this Pawn
will drop with a check and this would be
pretty much game over but uh in this
position I think instead of recruiting
with the black queen you can just
Retreat the Black Knight it looks a bit
scary but all the key squares are
covered White Queen can nearly slide in
this would nearly be Checkmate but
unfortunately the Black Knight covers
this Square so the queen would be
captured and unfortunately you're just
attacking with one piece Black's Pawn
structure does mean that white pieces
are unable to join the queens of uh the
queen in her assault okay kind of feels
like that night is actually in the way
if that night were missing and from the
board the White Knight that is yeah I
mean you could even get crazy and
sacrifice work and whatever but yeah
yeah it's it's in the way so and uh bear
in mind that black is always going to
go into play Queen Retreat and offer
that trade of Queens yeah and uh if this
doesn't work either then let's go back
to the drawing board what can Gary do he
would love to move this night out the
way he would love to Spring his Rook
into the center onto the open file but
it just takes too long if you move your
knight now for example then again the
black queen can just step back Retreat
also black does have the opportunity at
some point to go and capture this Pawn
remember it might be a two-point
sacrifice that Gary is committed to
struggling to see it as well and clearly
Geary had in hands he's struggling to
find the Breakthrough the computer does
indicate that there is a way to maintain
the balance for white but it's not a
drawish balance it's just maintaining
uh okay I I cheated and I can tell you
there's only one idea and that's
actually to put the queen over to the E3
square and this is clever because the
whole idea is that after you protect the
bishop now you're going to actually
break through with the G Pawn wow this
is not obvious the first move is
findable because you're attacking you're
pinning along this line but after black
defends the bishop wow Ivanka you're
right pushing this Pawn forward it looks
strong but it's not obvious to a human
you're weakening your own King this is
against every Instinct in Gary's body he
will not be looking for moves like this
the whole idea is now you're attacking a
pawn and if Pawn takes porn suddenly
your Bishop which was blocked out of the
game Springs to life and you're
attacking this pinned piece this bishop
is the target remember it is pinned
along the e-file so uh suddenly black is
under tremendous pressure
but I don't think he's gonna find this I
just doesn't it's the second move that's
so difficult to me pushing this Jeep on
yeah that's the only way to justify the
first move for me it's actually the
first move because I'm like the eyes are
kind of going forward and you want to
get your queen as close to the king as
possible yeah that's true she's already
well placed it looks like you want to
improve other pieces yeah and he doesn't
find any of the three best moves in each
giri he does play a very natural one he
captures the bishop but it's a natural
mistake as we just showed the queen
comes in but this can be safely defended
by Black's Knight retreating I think the
only move for black but it is sufficient
you defend this square and everything's
defended everything's covered actually
the black king feels pretty safe to come
and blockade this white porn next move
white is attacking with just one piece
it's not gonna work yeah I I agree and
there we see the move both the knights
cover all the critical squares
and now there's just really no way to
kind of break through immediately and
like I said you know that white knight
is in the way it's a traitor
yeah if it weren't there then so white
could do so many things I mean if you
could pick up this night and put it
anywhere if you could put it on the C5
square or the G5 Square you're just
winning with white but unfortunately you
just have bad pieces this Knight is bad
this rook in the corner unable to join
the action
yeah Gary he just hasn't coordinated in
time it was a very tricky move to find
to keep the balance but uh yeah this one
is not sufficient Magnus is going to be
at least a pawn up and he will reassert
control I think black is in time drama
and Anish has taked under two minutes on
the clock he's gonna need great air
quality right now Anish uh Geary of
course there is an air things device in
the San Francisco Arena monitoring the
air quality for the players and is the
air quality good that is exactly what a
niche Geary needs right now
yeah he needs to use every single
Advantage he can get and wow what hint
for the penny in for the pound and uh
a niche just sacrificing a bishop oh the
bar jumps up
it does look like decent air quality uh
there in San Francisco I'm not sure
that's going to help I need to get rid
of there because he has just given up a
bishop we talked about white tonight
needing to get into the game and it has
finally sprung to life and uh okay it
has come at the cost of the whole Bishop
though White's giving up a bishop for a
pawn just to break Black's Pawn chain
that previously proud chain of Pawns has
been
shattered and there are some weaknesses
some targets but there's no
I mean I just don't see any downside to
Black trying to force the Queens off as
we indicated Black's Queen now needs to
rejoin the action
and then I think you're just fine and
you're a piece up yeah
you have an extra night
and unless Gary can checkmates that's
going to be decisive
I agree David I think White's attack
isn't that strong and like you said it's
good uh good philosophy to trade of
Queens when the king is in danger yeah
let's just show an action replay of this
Sacrifice by Gary maybe it was just the
best practical tray otherwise he's
losing anyway why not at least
complicate the issue we talked about
these two pieces not getting into the
game he decided okay this bishop is
blocked by all the pawns anyway I might
as well just give it up he took a pawn
and the whole idea is that now when his
night Springs forward there's a threat
Knight takes pool that's the only threat
on the board but it is a bit of a scary
one it would hit the black queen it
would get slightly closer to the black
king so we're expecting now Magnus to
retreat and Gary's idea here must be to
capture this Pawn if the White Queen
runs away it doesn't have too many great
squares but if it steps back for example
Black's Knight can just move and you can
choose any safe Square I think here and
the queen exchange threat continues so
I'm expecting here if Magnus does
retreat for Gary to take this Pawn we
would see a queen exchange potentially
and at least now due to this last
capture he would be forking the king of
rook and okay he has gone for this so
this is his threat suddenly if this
happens we do a quick count it's a rook
for two nights and yes the two nights
are better long term but right now they
aren't so impressive and whites Rooks do
have targets uh white trucks can swing
and start hitting some pawns also
remember this Pawn's still alive the F6
Pawn for white a bit dangerous there so
does Magnus have something better in
this position do you think Ivanka than
swapping Queens giving giving some
material back by trading Queens would be
the safe option but maybe Magnus has
more yeah I was I was wondering at some
tactical ideas of actually moving the
Knight away but it doesn't seem to work
and I also wondered just move the king
relocate the king so this also was a
possibility but here I thought white
could just simply stand nothing much has
changed after Queen takes Queen there's
still the problem of Knight takes Queen
check for King The King and The Rook so
white can now use this time aim to
either attack some pawns or just
centralize a work yeah for example swing
across and is magnus's idea really to
capture this pawn it looks a bit too
brave here like King is out in the open
I'm not sure you can get away with that
while Queens are on the board just to
show as well Ivanka you're right black
can't quite Force the Queen's off yet
because uh this is this Fork is even
more deadly now and okay giri doesn't
take a time out just to improve his Rook
this would have been very tempting but
uh he goes all out now he's gambling
even more he's attacking this Black
Knight
the question is well if the Black Knight
just moves and Magnus has just retreated
it the problem now for Gary is that
there is a threat for black for the
first time in a while maybe of capturing
this Knight not immediately
um for example if the Rook moves if you
take this Knight the flat King is still
going to get the kiss of death as we
call it and there's still some
checkmating ideas against it but
yeah suddenly the Knight is loose the
queen always has to watch out for an
exchange and look at Black's Knights
they say a Knights are a king's best
friend and that's because these two
defend their King so well and you know
what I so reckon that Magnus is going to
capture that pawn on F6 I mean he has to
for example if there's a night check
hitting the king you pretty much have to
walk out into the open and take this
Pawn
but you're safe because the Queens are
about to come off exactly but I also
think even if a rook swings over that
porn would just find herself gone and uh
then suddenly Anita will have to deal
with the fact that his Queen's under
attack and also his Knight is under
attack and uh both things are going to
be very difficult to avoid yeah I mean
it's just a crazy position this is what
we wanted to see from this match but
it's not going in Gary's favor 20
seconds now on the clock and he's a
piece down on the board he needs
something he needs at least one trick he
needs to surprise Magnus somehow catch
him off guards set a trap for him but in
10 seconds 10 seconds and uh black is
also threatening to give a check with
the queen or you mean you need to make
it more money he needs to make a move
oh okay he captures a pawn how much time
did he have it I don't think he lost on
time otherwise we would have seen a
reaction he might have made that move
with one or two seconds left on the
clock I think just a small delay we'll
see that in a moment the clock catch up
he takes a pawn though and this doesn't
help at all
tonight I'm ready they can just capture
this Pawn back
I think you need to capture this Pawn
Black's King shouldn't move now Gary
looks away what has happened here
I mean it's at zero on the clock for him
probably it's not updated but what is
happening here he's in huge trouble he's
in massive trouble not just on that
clock but also on the board and Magnus
is just choosing which Knight to capture
this Pawn back with and uh I think
I mean you can choose either Knight here
to be honest and uh okay Magnus he's
using his time well but Gary what has
happened to his clock we want to know
they get 10 seconds increment after
every move so probably he hasn't lost
some time because he's still sitting
there so he should have at least 10
seconds on the clock at least to make
his next move he might have 11 seconds
left uh usually players they move when
they have one second and it's just in
time they're very good at timing it uh
playing it on the edge but
we want to see you want to know well one
thing that does happen when you lose on
time you don't really get an option this
little box comes up goes oh sorry you're
lost and that's it game restarted so we
do know that Anish did make that move
with some sackers despair maybe it's
possible to zoom in on the screen so we
can actually okay now we have the clocks
five seconds for a niche yeah he needs
to move the Black Knight did recapture a
pawn white gives a check but Black's
King is safe enough for now this is one
check but the king is driven actually
back where it wants to go driven back to
safety and initially he's kept the
Queens on the board that is step one you
repeat down you can't allow that
Exchange promise you're not getting
anywhere Black's King is well defended
well fortified
there are some tricks in the air that's
the only thing Anisha Guru can hope for
now he's got to Hope at some point he
can maybe give up a rook explode open
this line towards the black king
just don't think it's going to work
Magnus is going to do something we call
castling by hand he wasn't able to
Castle he had to move his King before
that was legal but now he's gonna
Shuffle his King into the corner and
he's going to run away
yeah and if the king runs away then
that's it it's going to be game over so
now is a time to do something just
macular just be desperate Rook takes
born and he instead he moves his work to
the d-line but if I were a niche sorry
if I were Magnus I would just move my
king away and there you go King is now
safest houses
trying we have to give him credit he is
desperately trying to open up lines yeah
to be fair to Anish if we weren't uh
privy to the evaluation bar if we
couldn't see the evaluation by saying
black is completely winning then the
nerves would still be jangling I mean
Magnus here he won't be 100 sure that
he's out of the woods that he's out of
danger yet he'll know that he's got some
control Magnus he knows he has an extra
piece of course but uh Anish is still
creating threats so Magnus needs to be
on his toes I would just try and lock it
up I would try and block this file there
we go don't capture a pawn don't open up
whites Rooks
and uh still full control for the
Norwegian so which king is the safest
Seafood is it safer now
for now but uh White's pieces are still
around White's Queen and night are still
close enough for the black king to feel
uncomfortable White's King is open but
there are no black pieces around it so
for now it's safe
um so your king is only as weak as the
pieces that are that are attacking it
and this is the problem for Gary look at
the Black Knights Black's King is open
yes but Black's nights are perfect
Defenders blacks Knight's so well
combined as well uh okay giri attacking
one of them [ __ ] they can defend each
other definitely and one of the another
problem is that of course Magnus has an
extra piece and he's using that extra
piece sometimes in some positions you
see that extra piece is just sleeping
somewhere but here very much part of The
Fray and uh Magnus being very clever
he's using the idea of counter-attack
and Anish he's just advancing pawns he's
just flapping around trying to find
something but now Magnus is going after
the white king finally the counter
attack begins look at the black queen a
diagonal has opened up she wants to jump
into G3 that would be a deadly check
leading to Checkmate Gary all down to a
couple of seconds but it looks like he
just resigned or let his clock run out
Gary gives up Magnus takes the win and
there we go the players talking about
what a dramatic game this has been